You're not gonna believe this, but we
have to talk about the Regressive Left today.
Believe it or not, I've been trying to get
away from discussing the regressive left on
The Rubin Report, instead talking about the
ideas of classical liberalism which I believe
in, but current events keeping dragging me
back.
I see on social media people are using the
phrase regressive left a bit less lately,
and replacing it with terms like Bigoteer,
the Control Left or the Illiberal Left.
Whatever name you use for these well meaning,
yet painfully misguided set of ideas is largely
irrelevant.
We needed to identify this backwards idea
which puts groups before people -- sometimes
you need a label to get people to understand
an idea.
The portion of the left who was no longer
progressive, meaning for progress, but regressive,
meaning going backwards, has been identified
and now we are clearly bringing people to
the side of reason.
All of you who talked to friends and family
about this, used the #RegressiveLeft hashtag,
and shared these videos are part of the political
awakening that is happening.
Yes, it seems like these leftists ideas are
getting stronger in some circles, but at the
same time, finally, for the first time in
a long time, those who are liberal and open
to new ideas are coming together and being
heard.
Whether you like Trump or not, his win was
a huge rejection the identity politics of
the Left, so loved by these regressives.
But don't take my word for it, Bernie Sanders
said that himself.
The only thing which can replace the regressive
descent the Left is on a return to true liberalism.
A liberalism which defends free speech and
expression, a liberalism that is for liberty
and rights of the individual, and most importantly
a liberalism that is one for human liberty.
I truly believe the regressive ideology is
the biggest threat to freedom and western
civilization that exists today.
With the rise of Trump and the constant comparisons
they make of him to Hitler, the Left now has
the perfect boogeyman to use to excuse anything.
If your opponent is a vile racist, then you
can use violence and any means necessary to
stop him.
The regressive left has already begun using
violence as a tactic and I fear that it's
just getting start.
If you're only now getting up to speed on
what the regressive left is, allow me to recap
quickly:
The regresssive/control/illiberal left, is
a group of people who place identity, usually
based on immutable characteristics, in a pecking
order of social importance, such as race,
gender and religion where victimhood is the
highest virtue to be had.
This oppression olympics allows groups to
compete for who is the most oppressed, thus
the most virtuous.
And if someone isn't as oppressed as you,
then you have full authority to oppress them
accordingly.
So Black Lives Matter can protest a gay rights
march in Toronto, white gay men can be banned
from leading LGBT organizations, pro-life
women can be kicked out of women's rights
march and so on.
This backwards ideology, which demands we
judge each other not on the content of our
character but on the color of our skin, or
some other baked in trait, puts the collective
ahead of the individual.
It loves all of its minority groups to behave
as monoliths, so if you're a true individual,
meaning you don't subscribe to the ideas that
the groupthink has attributed to you based
on those immutable characteristics, you must
be cast out.
Many of my guests have suffered from this
backwards backlash.
Ayaan Hirsi Ali, Maajid Nawaz, Sarah Haider
and Ali Rivzi, all have felt abandoned by
the Left because they speak out about the
problems within Islam.
They dare to fight for a more tolerant, more
truly progressive Islam in tune with a modern
society and basic liberal values, and they
are labeled bigots, or worse.
The Southern Poverty Law Center even labeled
Maajid an anti-Muslim extremist.
In reality, Maajid is a former Islamist who
has devoted his life to trying to reform Islam
from the inside, to try to reconcile his faith
with the modern world, fighting for gays and
athiests and women and any other free thinkers
living under theocratic rule.
For this he is called a porch monkey and other
vile names by supposed progressives, while
he is admired by many on the right for being
outspoken.
This the height of absurdity.
But it all makes sense when you value groups
over individuals.
The individual must be sacrafied at the alter
of the collective.
So when any of these people dare speak out
and call for true tolerance, they find their
tolerance met with intolerance.
The Left loves diversity in skin color, just
not diversity in thought.
Of course, this regressive ideology isn't
just tied to Islam at all.
My guest this week is Larry Elder, a black
conservative, who has had every label and
smear thrown at him.
Again, like with the previous guests I just
mentioned, these slurs come from people on
the Left, who would rather silence and dismiss
their opponents that actually engage them
in an honest way.
People often ask me which interview I've done
that's changed my views the most and I always
say it was the first time I sat down with
Larry Elder.
He challenged my views on systemic racism,
as well as the need for a strong family, was
one of the people that helped sell my on smaller
government.
If you haven't seen the video, we'll post
the link right down below.
Larry challenged me and I wasn't ready, so
I can't say it was my best moment on camera,
but I listened and learned and just as importantly
we didn't edit any of it out.
I'm looking forward to picking up where we
left off.
And as for where we left off, this is where
I feel there might be nothing left for me
on modern American Left.
You all know most of my positions on important
issues, I'm for free speech, even for white
supremacist Richard Spencer to speak and not
get punched in the face as happened just a
few days ago.
And I'm still am a card carrying liberal....I'm
for gay marriage, I'm pro choice, I'm pro
legalization of marijuana, I'm against the
death penalty and the list goes on.
At the same time I'm against this oppression
olympics, I'm against safe spaces and trigger
warnings, I'm against labeling all my opponents
bigots and racists and I'm against deplatforming
speakers, especially at colleges, where ideas
are meant to be challenged and debated.
I'm also for states rights, for following
the constitution, and most importantly for
having the government to get out of the way
for you to live your life to the fullest.
I've said a few times on the show that defending
my liberal principles has become a conservative
position.
Interestingly I've also heard conservatives
like Andrew Klavan and Dennis Prager say that
they are conservatives because they are liberals.
This is where we might get lost in the definition
of liberal in the modern sense versus classical
liberal, so if you're still confused about
that check out the video I did 'Why I'm a
Liberal' from a few weeks back.
The point is, that the issues I care about
most, free speech, rights of the individual,
and limited government designed to maximize
liberty have almost nothing to do with the
modern Left.
My positions basically haven't changed but
I've watched as my team has gone off the deep
end.
The battle of ideas always gets to a tipping
point and I sense we're closing in on one
right now.
If we can't reign in this madness on the Left
then Trump will show him his authoritarian
side.
Both sides are ramping up for a showdown.
It seems pretty obvious to me.
So while I absolutely believe that the new
center, filled with liberals, conservatives,
libertarians and others is rapidly growing,
maybe I have lost the Left.
And maybe that's OK.
But to end this Direct Message I now kick
this back to you.
If you're liberal is there anything Left for
you on the Left or are you Left Out?
Is it now the conservative position to truly
be liberal?
Let me know in the comments right down below
and we'll see if there's anything Left to
discuss.